we're clearly in the right place because
jeremy corbyn's coming to Glasgow as
well at later on today you see a help or
a hindrance to the Labour campaign north
of the border
he's a help because of the platform that
he's standing on what we've got is a
radical labor manifesto with a plan to
transform this country and right at the
heart of that manifesto is a plan to
raise living standards the idea that we
can left over 5 million people in this
country you currently go to work we
don't earn enough money to make ends
meet I used to fight in work poverty and
only the Labour Party's offering that
excuse me the SNP you don't offer that
the Tory stands firmly against it so
those types of policies that are about
lifting people up and helping them go
all in like this right at the heart of
what Jenny McCarthy stands for it's
interesting a choice of words that he's
a help because the policy that you the
platform that he's standing on it does
she feel according to the polls but the
Labour manifesto is quite popular with
voters but is the leader is the
messenger and if you look at for example
combos pull out today 51% of people say
to reason I make the best Prime Minister
compared to 30% Jeremy Corbyn and I mean
that is that is really not an outlier
when it comes to the polls this general
action is about the issues that matter
to people the length and breadth of the
country so it's not about leadership
them it's about the vision that your
leader has for your country so do you
want to carry on with the programme with
the Tories harm of austerity which
hard-working people that strip away
their rights that push for a hard right
wing breaks it or do you want the
alternative led by Jeremy Corbyn which
is about investing in public services
helping to grow our economy and lifting
people out of poverty now wherever I
travel across Scotland that manifesto is
incredibly well received because it's
such a radical change from what we're
currently faced with if you vote for the
SNP all you do is send MPs to campaign
for independence and to show to the
Tories if you vote for labour in Scott
we have a chance of getting the Tories
out of office and putting in that plan
that radical plan to transform this
country and who it works for and I'm
more than prepared to fight for that you
still talk about the manifesto they want
you not the leader well we have 1012
days left in this election campaign it
should be about the issues it's a great
position to you that so much of it has
been caught up in what we call the
process ecology of Elections who's up
who's down this polling that let's talk
about the future of a country what we
want for it and who has the best vision
for that I firmly believe this the
Labour Party it has the
is to transform this country to help it
grow and make sure everyone can fill
their potential and make sure we live in
a safer more secure society